Hello everybody, hope that you're good.
Don't get used to this. Three videos in
three days. Come on, don't get used to
this.
It's been because there has been some
movement and as I said, I like to show
up when there is volatility because I
know that there are a lot of questions
and emotions and
if it helps anybody that I say the way
that I'm trading this,
then, you know, I'm happy to to make
this update. So,
basically, what we've been saying since
Sunday has happened, okay? On Sunday,
I posted a very bearish Bitcoin Sunday
update, if you remember. We were above
110k, we were at 110,200
or 300, somewhere in this zone.
And I was saying that this looks like a
range and we have to be very cautious
because Bitcoin could very likely do,
you know, a drop, a 9-10% drop, and
that's what's happened in the last two
days,
towards the range lows. And not only
that, but it could very easily and very
likely, if it goes to the range lows,
also print a deviation right below it,
okay? Deviations, you know, very
clearly, you have here range highs,
range lows, price is doing this, you
know, testing resistance, support,
resistance, support.
The same as here, you can see here, you
know, you have here a resistance, you go
in this
orange line, some support. But again, I
was marking the range lows
on the 100% of this long week because it
also uh represented the weekly 50 MA, a
big imbalance, okay? And the potential
deviation idea to hit the stop losses
and the liquidations, okay? So, anyway,
in the range, you have range highs,
range lows, and eventually,
at one of the extremes, you have a
deviation, okay? And usually breaks in
the opposite side. So, my idea is that,
you know, having this liquidity pool
from the liquidation cascade, the 10th
of October,
and that liquidity pool, that imbalance,
hasn't been retraced yet. My idea is
that, you know, the end goal of this
range is to break to the upside and
start, you know, retracing this
imbalance at 121k. So, for that, it made
sense to print the deviation
at the range lows, okay? That was my
thought process behind all of this. All
right?
So,
I think that that's pretty much what is
happening, you know. You saw a very
sharp and aggressive 9-10% drop. Also,
you know, you're in a range, everybody
is getting tight, everybody is getting
frustrated. And that's where you see a a
relief rally, okay? Um
based on that, you know, that the the
chart is very very extended from the 50
MA in the 4-hour time frame, you can see
that the the 4-hour 50 MA is at 107k
still, okay? In the 1-hour time frame,
it's also very extended. Now, we're
starting to head towards it at 103k,
okay?
Then, it made sense to me to try some
longs
uh below the range lows, okay? And
that's what these yellow lines
represent. These are my orders.
I put I placed three orders. Two of them
got triggered, okay? And I placed them,
if you notice, also right below the
weekly 50 MA.
Why? Because if you go into the weekly
time frame,
you're going to notice, guys, how every
time we go to the weekly 50 MA, and it
acts as support,
we deep, we wick right below it. You
have it here, also here.
A couple of examples here. And
yesterday,
if I remove all of these,
it happened the same. It wicked right
below it, okay? So, that's what I was,
you know, adjusting my entries.
Quite aggressive entries, to be fair,
because, you know,
price was already dropping 9-10%. You
might think that that's aggressive
entering here. But when you have not
only one confluence, but you have three
confluences,
okay? Four four confluences.
If you want to add that the 50 MA in the
1-hour and 4-hour time frames is very
very extended from price,
four confluences.
Fifth confluence, you can add also
that price wicks always below the weekly
50 MA. Five confluences, okay? That is
not an aggressive trader.
That's not an aggressive trader trying
to open longs
in very interesting levels, okay? And
this is the way I trade.
So, anyway, place some orders at
100,350,
some at 99,160,
and then also, in case the wick went a
bit lower, I put some at 97,100.
This one was the biggest. This one was
to double down
all my entry here, okay? So, my average
would be
around 98k. Now, my average right now is
at 99,000 something, okay?
Um anyway, two of the three limit orders
triggered with very low risk.
So, you know, we're good. Now, the way
that I'm trading this
to take profits, all right? Um also, I
want to mention something, guys.
Yesterday,
in the in the Telegram channel last
night, I was mentioning that there were
some wicks
um that
they were going to get filled, okay?
Solana,
this one, okay? So,
you know, we I saw this long wick
um and I thought this one to get filled.
The next candle filled it. I just didn't
know when it was going to get filled.
Usually, it's right after, like this was
the most likely a scenario, but you
never know, so
um price went back to fill this wick,
okay? And now it's starting to recover.
The imbalance at the to the downside is
now
done. We don't need to go back down,
okay?
Um in terms of liquidity. So, now, yes,
now it's
um not a bad moment or area to start
thinking about longing if you if you are
more of a conservative trader looking
for confirmations, okay? If price
bounced without filling this long wick,
then, you know, you could have waited
and say, "Okay, price is likely going to
come back down to fill this wick and
then maybe from there we can start to
see a reaction."
All right? So,
also,
uh yesterday I was mentioning that roof
estimate for Solana to bounce could be
around 147, 150.
It got to 146.
Ethereum it deep lower. Ethereum, it's
true that it showed more weakness. I
think it went all the way to
3,060.
Quite a lot lower than I was expecting
originally.
So, Ethereum, I didn't touch it, to be
honest, okay?
But the same, long wick,
partially filled. I think that's around
40-45%
filled. We can consider it as 50. Let it
go.
Okay? And Bitcoin,
the same, okay?
We got a long wick
that it got filled right after. Now,
this long wick, the first one, let me
remove this so you can see better.
But in fact, hang on. Let me remove
this. Okay, so you have
this original long wick.
That's the imbalance. It gets filled
100% with
another long wick.
All right? Now, this long wick has only
been created to fill the previous wick,
which means that this second wick is not
necessary to get filled, okay?
Let it go.
And now, the way that I'm trading this,
you know, with those orders, is like
always,
with caution. Why? Well, let me let me
let me explain, okay? I also had a sixth
confluence, which was the timing. What
is the timing? You know, I follow
usually
a weekly
timing, like a it's some kind of a
pattern, like a
like a
weekly pattern.
And you usually see at the start of the
week the first move, you know, that's
the first move of the week, boom.
8-9% drop. And then on Wednesday
or Thursday is when you start to see a
reversal of that price move.
All right? So, you know, you have here a
very aggressive sharp move at right at
the start of the week.
And then, if you notice, Wednesday,
let's put the
1-hour time frame.
Look at these, guys.
You have in the 1-hour time frame also a
very long wick, this red candle, that
gets filled
by this other wick.
And then price can start to go up
because it has retraced
the big imbalance to the downside.
And that happens at exactly
1:00 a.m. on Wednesday. On Wednesday,
all right?
That is the the the signal also that
price could start to reverse,
to pull a reversal from there, okay?
It's Wednesday.
Um sorry that this video is getting
maybe a bit too technical, but I think
it's good to explain. And now, what I
want to say, guys, the way that I'm
taking profits on this
is also from a conservative
um point of view as a trader.
Um to me,
I look at the
at the calendar of this week, and all I
see is that on Friday, we have
unemployment rate, labor market data.
Careful. There might be some deviation
and some, you know, difficult price
action on on on Friday. So, I'm
obviously going to try to TP towards
Friday. Hopefully, on Friday, I'm flat.
Now, on Friday, maybe they release very
good news and price continues going up,
but you don't know that. So, to me, down
certainty is not worth to to trade it.
All right?
Um
if I want to start to TP towards Friday,
then I have to start looking at areas
where I can TP.
So, the first one is going to be the
1-hour 50 MA.
Why? Well, because 1-hour 50 MA,
you know, it was one of the reasons why
I took this trade because it was very or
very extended from price. It needs to
get retested. So, now price can go
there. And from here, we don't know what
it's going to do. We don't know if it's
going to break it, retest it, continue
going higher
or if it's going to come to test it and
then, you know, have a little drop again
towards this area here where you can see
price going up again. All right? You
don't know that, so I'm going to take
some profits at the 1-hour 50 MA.
Maybe around 1/3 of my position, okay?
And then
in the 4-hour 50 MA, I'm going to take
the rest. Because if you notice, the
4-hour 50 MA is also a level of high
significance
in the chart, you know, especially
lately. Support, resistance, resistance.
And now it needs to get retested again.
So, what I'm thinking is that, you know,
the 4-hour 50 MA is dropping very fast.
Now, if price manages
to and you're going to see better here.
If I change
in my indicator
and I put here the 1-hour
50 MA,
okay? Now, the two purple lines
Let me put it like this. The two purple
lines are the 1-hour 50 MA and the
4-hour 50 MA. So,
stay with me, okay? If you see price in
the 1-hour time frame breaking through
the 1-hour 50 MA, maybe can also retest
it as support and then continue going
higher, then that means that the 4-hour
50 MA is going to get retested. The
4-hour 50 MA, we are estimating that
it's going to continue going
uh down towards price.
That's normal. And it could line up
very close to this orange line. I want
to TP below this orange line because, as
you can see, it was a very strong
support that now could be resistance.
All right? So, based on this, I'm going
to keep an eye on the 4-hour 50 MA and
I'm going to TP
below this orange line, below 106k,
okay?
And that will potentially be the the 2/3
of my position, okay? And for that, I'll
probably get, you know, a 3%
4% increase in my total por- portfolio,
in the total trade.
Although I haven't risked it all because
I had some orders
here without getting filled.
So, I would consider that as a very
successful week in trading.
All right? So, that's the way I'm
trading that now. Then, if I completely
TP out of my position at the 4-hour 50
MA, if price continues going up,
then
I'll be looking for, you know, price
breaking above this orange line and also
uh that would need to be above the
4-hour 50 MA,
give me a retest and I can long again,
okay? Towards this area, towards this
area. All right? Sorry for the messy
chart. But um I hope that the idea is
clear, okay?
Um that's pretty much everything, guys.
I hope that you enjoyed the video, that
it was helpful. Again, it's not
financial advice. Um I highly suggest
you to join in my Telegram channel that
is free. The link is in the description.
And I'm posting a lot of content there
every day, okay?
Um that's it, guys. Thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon.